let's go live to Cleveland let's go live
to Cleveland and chris haynes who covers
the Cavaliers and the NBA for Cleveland
calm he joins us down Chris where are
you I'm right at the start of the parade
that's supposed to occur in about 35
minutes this I've never seen atmosphere
and environment like this people people
have been out here since midnight just
sign up parking get a decent spot at it
this crazy the city is Jack back right
now how many people are they expecting
wow I've her anywhere close to 800,000
to to possibly a million oh man how
would you describe the last 48 hours
though to somebody on the outside
looking in at Cleveland I think the
feeling is it's a surreal feeling some
people just can't believe that it
actually happened you know it is still
that moment uh uh you know it's protect
you know particularly how the Cavaliers
came back in the way they did it this is
something that this city and this reason
is not used to they're not used to you
know overcoming the eyes and be coming
out victorious that's exactly what
happened they did it on the grandest
stage in the most impossible way
imaginable and so I think this for a
right here is finally going to allow
people to kind of settle in and realize
that this is reality right now I don't
know if you spoken Richard Jefferson we
just had him on a half hour ago and it
doesn't sound like he's gonna retire he
said that LeBron and teammate said
you're crazy if you retire and he said
he's actually had he's got second
thoughts about retiring oh so he was
still in the moment of wouldn't that
title well yeah I haven't I haven't
spoken to obviously which is just a
half-game left me to say it was a big
part this seems you're doing a lot of
part of the season so I would be
surprised especially I think once
everybody gets the feel of this parade
yeah
went through these people I will
understand why a second thought when
does LeBron address his future Chris uh
I think you'll stall it out he has up
until June the 29th to make a decision
on if he's gonna opt out or not you know
if you go pie if you go by the recent
history he's always waited up until the
final day I think it is going to soak in
this moment the city of Akron is
actually honoring him tomorrow so I
don't think he's gonna dress anything
about its future you know anytime soon
but the fact that he won a championship
does does that open it up that now he
could go and play with Carmelo or Chris
Paul or do whatever he wants to do the
the possibility of that happening is it
greater now because he did deliver a
title that possibly could be the case
there are obviously I think if people
feel like they don't owe the city
anything anymore he came back he
delivered in a second year student in a
second step so obviously whatever he
wants to do I think he has to feel like
hey he did his part do I think he's my
least I will be very supply than if you
were to leave you know just considering
how this city and his team and you know
that is embracing him but I wouldn't
fault it if he has other aspirates the
plan in LA or going elsewhere I you know
that that should that should all
prerogative but yeah you know he did
something that nobody has done in 52
years in the south you have to live with
the city's first professional
championship so I can't fault her to
choose no other even winning a
championship doesn't seem to guarantee
that Kevin Love will still be with his
team well what is that scenario or the
possibility of that scenario well I
think the Cavaliers really have to look
at that you know in today's game the
game the speeding up smoke so fast so
quickly get a lot you know he was go to
state is just one of those pink I get
out there I and you know you talk
stretch fours in this league now how
they've taken over last four or five
years but now you get more to this the
stretch for versatile fours like
draymond Green guys that can handle the
ball and two other theory you see give
me an experiment with that in front of
play four doors at the four spot so that
few people does have to look at that and
say hey is this working we're paying
this guy 113 million is it worked it or
can we get a couple of guys cheap in
that can do multiple things and
different fashion and pump air up more
better with LeBron of Tyrese so the
Cavaliers I'm ticket this look at that
yeah I know quite now the religious i
enjoy appropriate corporations but they
don't have to look at crew hey Chris
thanks for joining us have fun today we
appreciate your time hey stop that
secure god that's Chris Haines Cleveland
Plain Dealer Cavs reporter the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience